we're joined on the line by dr. Marty
Meharry he's a health policy adviser to
presidents Trump and Obama
editor-in-chief of MedPage Today surgeon
and professor of public health policy at
Johns Hopkins and a patient right
advocate he is also the author of the
book the price that we pay offering a
coherent vision of how free market
solutions can restore quality
affordability and humanity to a
brokenness system dr. Meharry thanks so
much for joining the show great to be
with you Ben so let's start with
obviously the news that's on everybody's
mind this massive lockdown that's
happening in cities across the United
States
unprecedented really in American history
I mean outside of wartime but maybe even
inside wartime it's pretty astonishing
businesses across the land shuttering
how effective are these measures going
to be at containing the spread of the
virus and the bigger question for me and
the one I've been asking myself is let's
say that we lock down for 15 days or
even a month at the end of that when
everybody emerges from their from their
houses aren't we just going to get an
outbreak of this thing brand-new well
usually there is a community benefit or
sort of a community immunity and
actually in China I was talking to a
doctor there last night and they are
beyond the worst point they've peeked
and now people are starting to come out
and the case is presenting to the
hospital are way down the virus just
kind of poops out after a couple months
and we've seen this consistently Spanish
flu of 1918 that killed 25 million
people that lasted three months
September until January MERS SARS these
global pandemics with novel strains tend
to be about three months so with that
said the president suggested yesterday
that by July or August things may be
getting back to normal where would you
put the deadline for when you think yeah
things start to at least move toward
normalcy again I really think closer to
June we could probably get back to
normal and be in the clear I mean
they're they're probably being a little
conservative by saying hey just get
ready until July or possibly August the
more we can do to reduce the
transmission now now it's kind of in the
rapid spread phase the lower the peak
will be and that's what they call
flattening the curve that it sort of
spreads out and prolongs the pandemic
but we avoid that mass rush or we lower
it because that is our real threat right
now the good news about this virus is
that it is hard for
to really hurt a young healthy person it
can but it's hard and it will be over by
sometime in the summer that's the good
news the downside is a lot of folks are
sort of coronavirus deniers if you will
and as a recent study found that forty
percent of Americans don't even think
it's gonna be that bad or they think the
worst is behind us I'm concerned about
those folks because even though we might
look around and say hey I'm outside I'm
in the park we're having fun we're going
for runs none of my friends are sick
what's the big deal the reality is we
are community silent transmitters
sometimes symptomatic transmitters and
it's our most vulnerable that take a
heavy heavy hit and you know China has
not been transparent with their data at
all Iran has not been transparent no
surprise there but Italy has been
totally transparent and if we look at
the average number of deaths in one day
each day that is a preview of what we
can expect in the United States and
those numbers do not look very good for
us so the one that one of the questions
that I've been asking folks been asking
about the the corona virus here is what
happens in a second wave so the Spanish
flu had three waves the second wave of
the Spanish flu is actually the most
deadly presumably a vaccine is not gonna
be ready in time for fall which is when
presumably the summer weather would
would would sort of alleviate and you
might see an uptick again in corona
virus which means that really the only
solution at that point is we better have
expanded the number of ICU beds
available do you foresee that there
would be a second wave of the virus and
that this becomes sort of a normal part
of our flu season every year you know a
lot of viruses with novel strains do not
have a high reinfection rate or second
wave I think in China when I talk to the
folks there this week they are very
nervous about a second wave but so far
no indication that it's really got that
second wave I am worried about our
capacity look I'm worried about our
nurses and first responders and
respiratory therapists and Doc's look
health care workers the highest risk
individuals we only have a hundred
thousand beds ICU beds in the u.s. I
mean projections are showing 200,000
patients could be coming in for critical
care to two million patients
I think we got a look at the facts I
mean this isn't about data and facts
this is not fantasy football and you and
I know that we live in an era where
people like to blurt their opinions
without any real information right now
we need to look at what's happening in
data in Italy 350 deaths on Saturday
just on that one day extrapolated to the
US that is take that number adjust it
for the US population an age that's the
equivalent of 2,000 deaths in one day in
the u.s. three to six weeks before our
peak now I hope we don't get there some
say we might be worse because we're not
we didn't do an early quarantine like
they did somewhere in that ballpark we
could see a massive influx and I think
that's what the data are telling us to
do there's Figment dr. Marty Meharry his
book is called the price we pay and
we'll get to that book in just one
second dr. McCarran I want to ask about
the the sort of differential public
policy positions that have been taken by
various governments so we saw the UK
take a very different position and then
now they switched that position their
early position was we'll quarantine
basically everybody who is over the age
of 70 everybody else go about your
business because the economic impacts
obviously shutting down the entire world
economy are going to be extraordinarily
dire they're they're basically forcing
trillion dollar loan payoffs and and and
people signing cheques from that from
the government level the UK is now
reversed itself Denmark is not Denmark
is pursuing a policy of herd immunity
for people under the age of 65 and then
basically everybody over 65 should go
into into hiding
why is Denmark wrong why is it why is
the policy of the United States is
pursuing which seems to be at least on a
local and state level a giant lock down
why do you think the USS policy is gonna
be more effective than that of Denmark
well you know obviously people are
acting with the understanding that I'd
rather look back and say I was massively
over-prepared and maybe even overreacted
then get on the wrong side of this issue
again this is not a horse race or this
is not you know the World Series where
if somebody loses everyone will be fine
this could have being wrong on on this
could be could have mass fatalities I
think if you look at what we're learning
Singapore is some very
aggressive maneuvers early on to try to
test and trace now they are looking at
another sort of it's now out they
reported a lot of new cases this past
weekend so you know containment and
testing is good early on but at a
certain point the idea that it is
somehow contained as an idea we need to
abandon and everybody needs to take
extreme precautions I think I couldn't
agree with you more
Ben and you know what I'm concerned
about we're spending money like we have
an unlimited supply I mean we're just
spending money like crazy right and I'm
not even sure we understand exactly what
we're buying with that money and how
much more can we spend let's look at
what we actually need respirators we
need more awareness we have got to keep
essential workers on the job that is and
we define it very clearly healthcare
workers pharmacy supply chain food
service workers delivery even
restaurants that deliver and I would add
to that payroll financial services the
liquid the liquidity in the credit
markets if if that stuff goes if people
stop getting their payroll checks I mean
that could be much worse how are they
gonna buy food we just don't want and I
feel strongly about this
we don't want high risk people running
around active in society right now older
folks people over 70 maybe even people
over 60 people who are immunosuppressed
lung disease organ transplant on
chemotherapy those are very very
vulnerable folks we don't want them at
the workplace we're spending dr. Marty
Meharry health policy advisors to both
presidents Trump and Obama and the
editor-in-chief of MedPage Today so in
your book the price we pay you talk
about how free market solutions can be
brought to bear to our broken medical
system there's always been a lot of talk
about what the role of government is in
the medical system during a pandemic
you mentioned the shortage of ICU beds
only about a hundred thousand ICU beds
available across the country would that
be any better if we were talking about
nationalized health care system
obviously Italy does have a single-payer
system and they were completely
overwhelmed by the epidemic the the the
notion that this could have all been
solved preemptively by by government
simply
to what keep ICU beds empty that seems
like a very odd take away from this
situation but what what were the
benefits and the drawbacks of America's
health care system as this pandemic
broke out well we are seeing an increase
in capacity that we've never seen before
and I worry that if we didn't have our
strong private health care system we
wouldn't have that fluidity to expand
rapidly look we saw during 9/11
hospitals made fifty percent of their
beds available that is they quickly
mobilized and that's what we're seeing
right now the problem is there's only so
many respirators and you can't build
them quick enough so we need to reduce
the transmission rates so we don't get
that massive surge you know as you may
know and as I've told presidents and
from both parties
I have serious issues with nationalized
health care in the short term it is very
appealing you cut out some of the
middlemen that are price gouging
right but ultimately over time
governments invariably cannot resist the
urge to make across-the-board cuts in
the 10 or 20 years into it you are left
with a massively dilapidated healthcare
system you know I have met with
candidates and when they tell me let's
talk healthcare idea as I say okay tell
me your goals and they say expand
coverage and lower costs and I say okay
you know I love that we all love that
I'm sure there's some diabolical person
out there that doesn't want that but
those are wonderful ideas we are
currently spending 48% of all federal
spending on health care 48% nearly half
think about that when you file your
taxes we've done that study at Johns
Hopkins it's on restoring medicine or
guy published it in USA today almost
half of federal spending today goes to
health care in its many hidden forms I
tell the candidates what are you
proposing we increase that to seventy
five ninety two hundred percent do we
cancel all other national priorities
because it still won't get you there and
fund the system how about we cut the
waste how about we get price
transparency how about we create
efficient markets because the
fundamental problem in health care is we
have non-competitive markets the
temptation
for anyone who's looking on is to say
well let's create rules in those markets
the problem is they are non-competitive
and this executive order I worked with
at the pleasure of working with but the
White House will create competitive
markets if it is not overturned by the
Hospital Association lawsuit so back to
the back to the coronavirus topic for
just a second so if you're if you're
talking the american people right now at
you would you obviously are and you're
telling them what they can expect over
the next few weeks do you think that
these restrictions the heavy
restrictions that we're seeing in San
Francisco in Los Angeles in New York
that these do in fact last all the way
until June or do you think that this is
sort of a six-week thing and then it
sort of starts to let up that one of the
problems I've had with with the White
House response and maybe the the medical
industry's response to all this is
without people being told what kind of
timeline to expect here it's very
difficult to expect people to stay in
their homes indefinitely when we say
sort of until further notice everybody
who has three kids thinking themselves
are you insane until further I'm staying
in my house with my three kids and until
further notice this could be a year like
well what do what do we said three
months until the actual let up is what
you think is going to happen but how
about how much until people actually are
getting back to to work even sort of
part-time until until people start
eating at restaurants including with
social distancing for example I honestly
think it'll be late May or June that we
sort of are able to get out there but I
would point out go outside be on your
property go to parks walk sunlight is is
very therapeutic and it also it's hard
for that virus to live out there in the
Sun so it is good to be out there I do
think people are gonna get stir-crazy
but hey this is a once-in-a-generation
pandemic the worst since polio far worse
this is hurricane katrina about to hit
our shores except over a hundred times
more deadly we have a lead-up period
I've been encouraging people to go to
the grocery store and make sure those at
risk have enough food for three months
we don't want hoarding and we don't want
you know people clearing things out and
being selfish it would be unethical for
anyone have more than three months of
food but people should get ready and
we're seeing in other cities is that
they're having folks go out one every
three days can one out of every three
days somebody can leave the home to go
to groceries or for a family emergency I
don't know if the government's can
impose that in the United States but I
do think the private sector is already
getting smart and basically executing a
lot of these specs best practices
well dr. Marty Meharry health policy
advisor to presidents Trump and Obama
editor-in-chief of MedPage Today surgeon
professor of public health policy at
Johns Hopkins his book is the price
where you pay we pay go check it out
right now all about how to fix America's
broken health care system
dr. Meharry really appreciate your time
and thanks for all the information good
to be with you Ben
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content